happy New Year dude happy New Year man
2023 how long can we say it
how long you're like happy new is that
what you meant that is how long can we
say no what's the last day to say Happy
New Year we
I've done this before yeah but what's
the last day you think
um I feel like you can say it up until
half the year is over
no no but then you can keep saying it
because then you're early for 2024.
so you can actually say it all year
round
I think we have to keep it up yeah let's
do it we should actually kind of do that
every single episode yeah happy New Year
man yeah and to the get into the
audience too happy New Year happy New
Year yeah
so anything different 2023 feel good
feel I feel like you know strong
confident going into this year yeah I
think I think this is the one though you
know what
I've seen a new year new me oh yeah yeah
no I'll get in here what
it's another Noel oh she said new me hey
how's it going yeah good
for
all right yeah oh you're new so I'm
gonna head out oh I see okay yeah oh
thanks so much so oh I got you man oh
literally
all right okay yeah good to see you yeah
Happy New Year
okay
well let's get into it
uh before we do though do you there's a
quick question do you [ __ ] with race
cars
let's [ __ ] can go pumped for this year
baby everyone knows Ricky leave some
nice comments and love for Ricky our
editor one of
um that coffee is looking like what's in
my ass right now what do you mean
yeah it's it tastes bad it probably
tastes what's like what's going to come
out yeah too at Taco Bell last night oh
no bold let's go I don't I don't know
why I don't know why live Moss
yeah right yeah [ __ ] yeah you ever just
yeah late night you just want to live
Moss yep yep all the time yeah and you
do yeah I live Moss less and then you
[ __ ] Moss yeah the thing is I haven't
had a movement yet oh okay so she's uh
still Brewing she's turned she's gonna
turn over at some point are you no
you're no uh oh yeah I guess I am going
Raw yeah no headphones man
ah speaking of which I gotta tell the
story
I gotta tell this story about going raw
yeah yeah I'm kidding but it is related
um what
huh oh [ __ ] okay before I do that we got
brand new merch yeah thanks
Ryan has to literally sit on the ship
and stare at us to get us to do this but
I'm actually excited for this because
this these shirts are [ __ ] fire Jim
did another amazing little piece here
absolute slapping let me just keep
moving it so you can't focus on
yeah these are really dope read the
caption I'll read it as you can see here
really really sick design
if
there if you've never smoked weed at
literal Woodstock you're not a stoner
goodbye
and then we got some some leaves here
and some cool the cool TMG so
overall I'd say it's a slapper or can
you get this t-shirt uh uh tmgstudios.tv
or tmgpod.com
the old URL if you're in you know if
you're like an old.reddit.com user yeah
maybe you want to hit the TMG pod link
within a vintage link so who did you get
pregnant no no no no no no
that's not what it that's not what
happened
so we're we're she got me pregnant I
feel bad I don't want like I don't want
to like embarrass my mother she's a
she's like the sweetest human in the
world but I do have to tell a story
because it's so funny okay
so we're like doing a puzzle we just
started it so there's like a thousand
pieces lying all over the kitchen table
and she made you yeah I'm like doing the
edge no sorry I'm doing the edge pieces
and she she was like do you want the
picture
and I was like no I don't need it she's
like oh you're just gonna raw dog it and
I was like
what and my sister's like Mom
what don't say that and she's like oh I
I don't know what it means I've just
heard other people say that
I was like never say that again please
never say that again
she looks right in my face I was like so
you're just gonna raw dog it
mom what what
and she was so so funny put the camera
on me Helen keep saying it so no keep
saying ever say it Greg say it both of
you say it no just everything no no
sandwich sandwich without mayo it was
scarring
yeah it's gonna raw dog this sandwich
we were kind of saying it like as a joke
afterwards yeah we kept using it as a
family yeah
it's a little family inside joke now
like to break that one reverse family
joke
who wants dinner
[Music]
so did you eat the whole puzzle or did
you finish putting it together I didn't
eat the puzzle
there was a piece missing though
I might have popped that one in I don't
know I think it's funny just a group of
people doing a puzzle and someone just
comes
piece of chicken on it I got confused
you know you're the one who chose to do
the 12 disciples there shouldn't be so
much food on the [ __ ]
Jesus shouldn't have had food out he
should have taken more seriously yeah
so uh so did you for New Year is he just
little family
did nothing nil for New Year's yeah no I
went to we went to out for dinner we
flew back on New Year's
uh
flew into Orange County John Wayne
Airport she rolls they have an airport
yeah it's way better um
and then just like went out for dinner
and then came back and I fell asleep at
8pm and then woke up at 11 30. watch the
ball drop
then goodbye and then back to sleep hold
on what'd you do why did why does why
does the John Wayne Airport rule I've
never been there it's just small like
it's just any anything's better small is
better yeah exactly small is good size
does matter small is actually preferred
smallest convenient yes it's not crowded
yep
um that's cool
New Year's Day yeah no no New Year's Eve
New Year's Eve yeah was the airport a
nightmare or was it no it wasn't that
bad that's what I'm saying there was no
flights to LAX that's why we booked that
one oh and it just turned out to be
better God yeah God what'd you do we
just had a little
a little kind of [ __ ] big a little last
minute pasta party oh pasta party yeah
okay it's like Nema hit me up he's like
what are you guys doing I was like
[Laughter]
we bullied him pretty hard
so we got we gotta be nice he did he did
text me did he tell you he started DJing
as a bit no not as a Betty he used to DJ
I guess in college
oh and he he hit me up and he's like hey
man you got time for a quick Serato
question
and I was like I don't know how to use
Serato man and he then he sent me a
video of himself like just sitting in
his room like practicing a transition
and that [ __ ] was ass
[Laughter]
sorry Nemo but that was bad
but then he sent me a video the next day
and he was like I've practiced a lot and
it was still ass
but it was a little better yeah yeah
he's getting he's getting better and I
was like dude let's DJ together that
dude is like the most genuine assault
yeah I know he's amazing he's amazing
but I mean his transitions [ __ ] suck